イース gf
皆さんこんにちはん
僕はフランボタンが目えーじゃあを地点でまあ会社のサービスを作っています
とくる毎朝通勤電車に乗っていいしているんですけれども
そこで
毎回腹立つことがあるんです
それは
入線席で座って寝ているサラリーマンです
いやー
座れないんですよでも命令のはアウターがあると思ってるんですよ
そこに座るのが誰か来た時にすぐに揺れるように構えておくのがそこにつわり奴が責任
が
と思ってるんですよ
ある日のことです
そのサラリーマンの前に
おばあちゃんが立っていました
僕は
負債てるんだよとれてる婆じゃねえと早く起きろ
てが本当にね程度パワーやってそんな感情で
阿部れていたんです
でも僕がそれと同時に想像さんがもしこのおばあちゃんが
この目の前でサラリーマンに声をかけて
すいません私足が痛いんで席を譲っていただけませんか
と言えたのがどうなるかを習ってそれがさあです
間違いなく席を譲るなって想像できたんですね
てということはここで問題であったのは
からサラリーマンが座って寝ていることではなくて
思いが伝わってないことがあっていう風に考えました
それから思いが伝わる仕組みさえあればこの問題が解決できると思ったんです
それからその仕組みを考えました
簡単です
スマホのグルー酢を使って
バックグラウンドで勝手につなげるんですこれは bluetooth なので近くに
いる人を通して伝えるんですね
そうするとどうなるかというと
おばあちゃんがその後でそういった祝って全てみすって
そうなるとですねどうなるか
家帰ったら人に残念ですからメッセージがき今それたいわっ
そうすると戦役フリーター1ああっあるオーバーチャンス読みたいのか
0どうぞって何9分ができるんです
僕この仕組みを考えついた時や保育こう言って世界か悪いジェリーと思ってすっごい
興奮したいです
で僕はこれ作りましたで今これを広げる活動というのを行っています
で僕が
これを作ろうと思った理由をよく深堀りしていくと
この電車での出来事はきっかけに過ぎアイコンポンプ部分が他にあることに気付いたん
です
それは
遺伝子に問題人災での出来事です
この日のことはまあ皆さんも鮮明に教育にあると思います
このにこのときに本性がとった行動というのは世界の多くの人々から賞賛されました
この二面性が全く動かなくなって
明日もちろん長蛇の列に整然と並ぶ人で他の姿
被災地で
まったく物資が届かない中でねー
自分の家族のブースが取れない状況で
どうか
使ってください動画食べてくださいと奪えることはおろか
音ズレあっている姿を見てなんて言う国民なんだって世界の人々がショーンさんして
くれたんです
ピンクが不能
とっていいほど日本人であるということを
くら次回思ったことはありませんでした
自然を
そのに僕は
その誇りに疑問を感じる出来事を経験しました
元は当時伸ば首位で働いていました
今では千葉にその頃住んで言ったので20キロほどあったんですけれどもどうしても家
に帰りたくて
歩いて帰ることを決めて快勝でました
愛知時間ほどある意図でこのところでまぁ命令起立
設定そこで僕が見た光景というのは
澤岻お待ちアラブ長蛇の列だったんですね
おそらく枢軸には並んでいたと思います
服はちょうど上野駅で待ち合わせをする約束をしていたのでその
列の光景を縛りまあ眺めていたんですね
プレイするとですねタクシーは数分に一度プロしか来ない状況だったんです
私がきます
先頭の人一人が乗って出発していたんです
次のお客し焼きますまた戦闘の人一人だけが持って出発してみました
僕はこの光景を見てすごく違和感を感じたんです
タクシーには
あと3年入れます
で後ろには生100人というタクシーに乗れずに家に帰れずに困っている人たちがいる
んです
せません
横浜方面に行くんで誰か一緒に乗っていくといいますか
吠えを立てたらいいじゃないですか
でも誰もん
これを感じてる人なんていなかったんです僕は
でも皆さんは
声をかける方がまあいいよなって
感じているはずなんです
じゃあ何故
声を抱けないんでしょうか
もちろんこのタイプといえば
だが玉一人で売らないといけない状況だっていう人もいると思うんですが
おそらく多くの人が感じないっている感情っていうのは
恥ずかしいだと思うんです
すいません
だけ飲んで行きませんかって言って注目されるのが恥ずかしいんじゃないかって思うん
ですね
状況整理します寝る前には
thule プリンの困っている人たちで手を上げさえすれば
声をかけさえすれば山林助けることができるでも恥ずかしくて
やらないん
めっちゃプリンターしたいと思いません
うんスッキリクック悪いと思うんですね
甲塚 c というくっだらない感情でいいと思ったことすらやらないんですよ
女のが誇れる日本人なれたって思ったんです
ザーン
そんな奴もに入ってるお前は何かやったるかという声聞こえてきそうなのでお答えし
ましょう
何もやってません
何もやってないんです元気にヤバイっすよねー
いううううううっ
うようお前そんな偉そうに入れたなか話なんですけど
なああのん
だってですよちょっと想像してほしいんですけどじゃあ僕がそのタクシーの街待ちの列
に入ってちょっと後残念がありますよ
なんでの不ないんですか早くてあげてください結びクスってくださいスター
めっちゃ歳ですよ僕もう
なんかだいぶメール急いじゃってやったらと思われてじゃあ逆にキレられるかもしれ
ない水
なんか
そんなことをやっぱり考えるんですよ
それから僕も恥ずかしいし強いんですよ
だから弄ったんだできるわけじゃないんですよ
だって僕めっちゃ考えたんですよこんなのダメだぞ
絶対だめ夜中によくないえっめちゃくちゃ考えた僕が声かけれないんですから
みんなが打っているわけがないだから僕は
仕組みを作っているんです思い出使ったある仕組みを作っています
皆さんに
澤岻一緒に乗りたくないのに乗るべきだとか
うーんセキュリティくらいのに鼠べきだとかそんなことが入ったゆず熱低
皆さんは譲ったほうがいい
と思ったり
人にイーグルをしたいと思っていたり
そう思っているにも関わらず
それがスターっていないことが持った良いと思っているんです
その思いがそのまま伝わるだけで変わる世界があるんです
レバー
タクシーねぇなんで待ってます
先頭の人が横がの方免疫取って攻め相手
後ろに並んでいるあなたによく本も本命にとってエッセイ時できたとしたならば
ほんじゃあ一緒に住んでくださいっているのはができるじゃないでしょうか
福例えば
役の
本営
目の見えない方が詰まっていて
それでいきたいなぁと思っていて
それでいきたいて呟いて
仕掛けの人にそれが伝わったら
ムースあなたに
伝わったらあなたがスマホにメッセージがきて目の前のこの人がトイレ行きたいんだっ
ていうことを
ちったぁならばあなたはどうすれかということを聞きたいんです
細谷ぺほとんどの人は普通に
助けると思うんですよ
でも一時も生活していると
人に声を受けるとか人助けをするっていうのはそんなにないんじゃないかなと思うん
です
それは
すらメール体だと僕は思っています
もしそれが
ったは自分に伝わったら行動することができる
それは元もでも私たちは持っているからです1-8ピリッとしたいとか
いきたい人にいい人したいとか優しくありたいっていうのをもともと持ってるんで
知れだけで行動できるんです
僕は
こんな世界を作りたいそのために
今
この仕事をやっています
お前が伝わるだけで変わる世界がある
どうもありがとうございましたーーー